Traductor: Carmen de Miguel-Murado
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
En España somos 47 millones de personas,
de los cuales, alrededor de 4 millones
tienen diagnosticada alguna discapacidad.
Si a eso unimos sus familias,
son unos 10 millones de personas
relacionadas directa o indirectamente
con la diversidad funcional.
La pregunta es:
¿Por qué nos cuesta tanto al resto
relacionarnos con la discapacidad?
¿Por qué muchas veces ni les vemos?
¿Por qué seguimos manteniendo
una mirada caritativa hacia ellos?
Y sobre todo ¿por qué es tan difícil
cambiar esa mirada?
Embarazada de 8 meses,
la ginecóloga me dijo:
"Las cosas no vienen de carril"
Era su manera de decirnos que nuestro hijo
tenía una serie de malformaciones
que iban a dificultar mucho su desarrollo,
si llegaba a nacer.
Y así fue, el 4 de febrero de 2009
nació Mateo,
y efectivamente, las cosas
no vinieron de carril.
En ese momento todo se fundió a negro.
A partir de ahí empezó
un viaje de médicos,
palabras imposibles de pronunciar,
pronósticos inciertos
y lo más duro de todo: ningún diagnóstico.
Nadie era capaz de decirnos
qué le pasaba a Mateo.
Viví momentos muy duros,
no lo quiero dulcificar.
Entre otras cosas porque me molestan
esas frases que decimos,
de manera bienintencionada
en estos momentos:
"Estos niños son una bendición",
"te ha elegido a ti porque seguro
que eres una madre extraordinaria".
Y no, no es una bendición
ni es nada que desees a nadie,
pero como toda adversidad,
esconde una oportunidad,
la oportunidad de cambiar la mirada,
de ver las cosas desde otra perspectiva.
Durante mucho tiempo
yo estuve centrada en las cosas
que mi hijo no iba a ser capaz de hacer,
y prestando poca atención
a las que sí hacía,
que eran especiales y que,
además, él solo podía hacer.
Perdida en un mundo de noes y de límites,
porque cuando te ocurre algo que
nunca pensabas que te ocurriría a ti,
también hay una pérdida de identidad.
Yo dejé de ser Inés para convertirme
en la mamá de Mateo,
mientras peregrinábamos
de médico en médico,
sin encontrar respuestas.
Y además de esa pérdida de identidad
me tuve que enfrentar
a salir a la calle siendo otra yo,
pasar de ser alguien a quien nadie miraba
cuando caminaba por la calle
a que todo el mundo girase la cabeza
cuando paseaba con mi hijo.
Esas miradas que tanto duelen
pero que ni siquiera sé si yo miraría así
si no hubiera hecho
este extraordinario viaje,
porque todavía lo diferente nos asusta.
En la era de Instagram,
de parecer perfecto,
de parecer antes que ser,
lo diferente, nos asusta.
En la era de "consigue tus sueños",
"hemos venido aquí a disfrutar",
"si quieres, puedes",
ver reflejado lo frágiles que
en realidad somos, nos asusta.
Miedo, ese miedo a pensar:
¡Uf, si me pasara a mí!
¡No sé si sería capaz de superarlo!
Pues ahí va una buena noticia:
sí podrías,
no tienes otra opción, porque al final
tú eres tú y tus circunstancias,
y la única manera de sobrevivir
es aceptarlas,
aprender a convivir con lo que te pasa.
¿Y qué me estaba pasando a mí?
¿Por qué era todo tan difícil?
¿Por qué si en España hay casi 4 millones
de personas con discapacidad
era para mí algo tan ajeno?
Y sobre todo ¿qué es la discapacidad?
Empecé a leer mucho
sobre qué es la discapacidad,
qué significa, qué implica,
pero todo lo que leía
me hablaba de limitación,
falta de, incapacidad, minusvalía,
porque seguimos midiendo
la diversidad funcional
desde la limitación,
les etiquetamos médica y socialmente
por lo que no son capaces de hacer,
y eso no me hacía sentir cómoda.
Hasta que me encontré con una definición
que hace la Organización
Mundial de la Salud,
que dice que la discapacidad
es un fenómeno complejo
que refleja la interacción
entre una persona
con unas características determinadas
y la sociedad en la que vive.
Y eso sí era lo que estaba buscando.
La discapacidad no es
una condición de salud.
Refleja la interacción,
nuestra convivencia.
Somos nosotros, la sociedad,
los que generamos o
eliminamos las barreras,
somos el factor limitante.
¡Qué responsabilidad, eh!
Pues es así.
Ese fue mi primer cambio de mirada,
entender que el límite
estaba en mí y no en Mateo,
y yo, que llevaba mucho tiempo trabajando
en la cultura, empecé a preguntarme:
¿qué estamos haciendo los creadores
y los gestores culturales
por incluir la diversidad funcional?
¿Refleja nuestra cultura esa diversidad?
Evidentemente, no.
Por no hablar del acceso a la cultura,
que está además
recogido en la Constitución.
¿Puede una persona con discapacidad
acceder a la cultura
en igualdad de condiciones?
Tampoco.
Así que me puse a buscar soluciones.
Me encontré por el camino con uno de esos
seres excepcionales, Miguel Cuerdo,
y juntos pusimos en marcha el festival
"Una mirada diferente"
en el Centro Dramático Nacional,
con esa idea, cambiar la mirada
hacia la discapacidad
desde las artes escénicas,
empezando por subir a los escenarios
a creadores con discapacidad
que hasta entonces habían estado relegados
a circuitos amateur o al arteterapia,
les dimos la oportunidad de mostrarse
de manera profesional en un escenario,
porque lo que no se ve, no existe,
pero lo que se ve, depende esencialmente
de cómo lo mostremos, y desde ahí,
desde la potencia del escenario,
cambiar la mirada de los espectadores,
mostrarles la capacidad que hay
dentro de la discapacidad
y que dejen que la diversidad
les enriquezca,
y poco a poco, nuestros patios de butacas
empezaron a llenarse
de un público diferente,
un público que antes sentía que
lo que hacíamos no era para ellos.
Uno de estos espectadores, ciego,
nos contaba que cuando él era pequeño
y en el colegio les llevaban
al teatro de excursión,
a él lo dejaban en clase porque, para qué,
y se quedaba solo en clase
mientras los demás iban al teatro.
No hace tanto de eso.
Y ese público que antes era excluido
empieza a encontrar espacios culturales
que sí piensan en ellos,
y aplican soluciones para hacer
su propuesta accesible para todos:
la lengua de signos,
el bucle de inducción magnética,
la audiodescripción,
la lectura fácil, etc.
Y el público que sí venia, el normalizado,
empieza a mezclarse con un público nuevo,
y sobre todo empieza a comprender
el esfuerzo que implica
una cultura para todos.
Pero eso no era suficiente.
También queríamos que
el resto de creadores vieran
que la diversidad en escena
enriquece la propuesta
si se hace de la manera adecuada.
que perdieran el miedo a trabajar
con artistas diversos,
y les pusimos a trabajar juntos
en espacios de investigación escénica,
que pudieran probarse, retarse,
sentirse en entornos creativos,
y pasó lo que esperábamos:
los miedos, las barreras, los prejuicios
empezaron a derrumbarse.
Y estos creadores empezaron a contagiarse
de esta belleza que aporta la diferencia.
Y empezaron a incluirlo
en sus propuestas artísticas.
Laila Ripoll y Marga Labarga
dirigieron "Cáscaras vacías",
un cabaret sobre el nazismo interpretado
por actores con diferentes discapacidades.
Se estrenó en el teatro
María Guerrero, de Madrid,
y fue un éxito tan grande,
que tuvieron que reponerlo
al año siguiente.
Andrés Lima nos contó
su versión de Romeo y Julieta.
El amor no dura para siempre.
Interpretado por actores
con discapacidad intelectual
a los que se les dio la oportunidad
de hablar encima de un escenario
sobre el amor y las relaciones de pareja.
Un colectivo al que rara vez se le permite
amar de manera adulta,
hablando sobre familias
que impiden amar a sus hijos.
Fue una revolución.
Hay un momento en que Julia,
una de las actrices,
dice mirando al público:
"el amor es justicia".
O Lucía Miranda, que nos mostró
sus "Alicias buscan maravillas",
en el que todos los personajes
tenían alguna diversidad.
Porque, ¿por qué no puede Alicia
tener discapacidad?
Es verdad que en el libro
no dice que la tenga,
pero tampoco dice que no.
Abramos nuestra mente,
cambiemos la mirada.
Y poco a poco otros creadores
empezaron a interesante
por esta nueva forma
de hablar de lo diferente.
Y nuestros escenarios han empezado
a reflejar la diversidad de otra manera.
Y aquello que empezó siendo un sueño,
poco a poco se va convirtiendo en realidad
Nos queda mucho trabajo por hacer,
un trabajo muy complicado.
Pero escuchar a Patti Benet, actriz ciega,
decir que cuando fue a matricularse
a una escuela de interpretación
le dijeron que no, porque ella
nunca iba a ser actriz profesional,
y que termine trabajando como actriz
en el escenario María Guerrero de Madrid.
O ver a Ángela Ibáñez, actriz sorda,
estrenar ayer mismo "Madre coraje"
junto a Blanca Portillo
en el Centro Dramático Nacional.
O ver a Jesús Vidal recoger su Goya.
Solo por todo esto,
el esfuerzo merece la pena.
Un Goya, que lo he dicho así, alegremente.
Pero qué momentazo fue ese, por favor.
Yo creo que este año
ningún actor quiere ganar el Goya,
porque tiene que superar el discurso
de Jesús Vidal del año pasado.
¡Suerte con eso!
Inclusión, diversidad, visibilidad.
Tres palabras que ya forman parte
de nuestro imaginario
y de nuestra historia.
Algo impensable hace solo unos años.
Porque el viaje de "Campeones"
también ha sido un viaje increíble.
Supongo que todos la habréis visto ¿no?
Porque ¡menudo exitazo!
Yo tuve la suerte de que Javier Fesser
me llamase al inicio del proyecto
y formar parte del equipo de casting
y luego ser la coach de interpretación
de los diez actores con discapacidad.
¡Imaginaos qué regalo!
"Campeones" es un modelo de inclusión,
porque no muestra la parte limitante
y negativa que hay en la discapacidad,
muestra lo bueno que tiene que ofrecer.
Y en una sociedad en la que peleamos
constantemente por ser el primero,
viene "Campeones" y nos habla
de lo maravilloso que es quedar segundo.
¿Dónde están los segundos
en esta sociedad?
Y esa sociedad que mide el éxito
en términos económicos
como la rentabilidad, la productividad
o el reconocimiento social,
viene "Campeones" y nos habla
de que también se puede medir
en valores como la felicidad y
la capacidad para disfrutar de la vida.
Vivir "Campeones" junto a
los protagonistas y sus familias
fue para mí una experiencia increíble.
¿Cómo empezamos? con mucho miedo,
porque la comedia traza
una línea muy fina.
Y había gente que podía pensar
que nos estábamos "riendo de"
en lugar de "reirnos con".
Pero todo lo que vivimos en aquel rodaje,
ya solo eso, mereció la pena.
Porque Fesser tenía muy claro que era
la historia de ellos la que quería contar,
por eso hay tanta verdad,
por eso funciona "Campeones",
porque ellos no han tenido que parecerse
a nadie para encontrar su sitio,
solo han necesitado a alguien
que les mostrara tal y como son,
con sus capacidades y
con sus limitaciones,
como las tenemos todos.
Y el mensaje ha sido tan potente
y tan bien contado,
que ha transformado a una sociedad entera.
¡Ojalá no se nos olvide!
"Campeones" nos ha hecho avanzar
diez años en inclusión.
Y ha hecho que, para el colectivo
y para sus familias,
el esfuerzo de tantos años
merezca la pena.
Por cierto, Mateo sale en "Campeones",
es solo un segundo, casi no se le ve,
cruza por ahí, vestido de verde,
con su abuela, muy emocionado,
de lado a lado.
A Fesser le hacía mucha ilusión
que él saliera,
y a nosotros, ¡imaginaos!
Porque no puedo evitar
acordarme de aquel día
en el que todo se fundió a negro
y yo pensé que me hundía,
y no podía ni imaginar que esa adversidad
escondía una oportunidad
tan grande para mí
y para tantas otras personas,
pero sobre todo para Mateo.
Él es el motor de todo esto.
Trabajo para que mi hijo crezca
sin miedo a ser diferente.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
La diversidad se tiene que
mostrar en nuestra sociedad
de una manera naturalizada.
No tenemos que estar
constantemente contextualizando
y explicando la diversidad.
La vida es diversa, la gente es diversa,
la inteligencia es diversa y
nuestro mundo es diverso,
y eso es lo que lo hace rico.
No lo compliquemos queriendo
adaptar a todos a la norma.
Generemos contextos y
entornos más flexibles
donde las personas con discapacidad
puedan ser y hacer a su manera
sin tener que parecerse a nadie
para recibir el premio de ser incluido.
Porque incluir significa
adaptar el medio a la persona.
Somos nosotros los que tenemos
que transformarnos,
dejar que la diferencia nos enriquezca,
y claro que la inclusión cuesta, y mucho.
Cuesta tiempo, dinero, esfuerzo, recursos,
pero no hay otra opción,
porque al final del día
¿tú quién quieres ser,
el que pone la barrera
o el que pone la rampa?
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)